all right so let's talk about two
towns or cities or states that are
trending certainly
in different directions here we go we're
talking about obviously new york city
and then
our previous home state of
dallas texas uh manhattan and brooklyn
new lease signings surged in january
both boroughs had the most new leases
during the month of january since 2008
since
right before the housing crisis the
number of leases
of new leases signed in manhattan are up
57
from january last year meanwhile
brooklyn had a
46 increase from january 2020 so both
boroughs are up almost 50 if not a
little bit more
um where's the rest of the story hold on
bear with me guys
tell you what i wasn't expecting to hear
these headlines about what's going on
here we go here we go here we go both
boroughs have seen increases
in new lease signings which does not
include
lease renewal so new leases because of
the continued decline quote unquote
because of the continued decline
in net effective median rent record
concessions
and high vacancy aka rent prices are
going down
throughout the course of the coronavirus
pandemic new yorkers have been fleeing
the big apple don't we know it
to live in suburbs and other states wink
wink florida
all together and because of that flight
rental prices go down this is supply and
demand this is economics
101. median rental prices in manhattan
are down 16 percent compared to last
year
and median rental prices in brooklyn are
down 13 percent
so basically rent went down because
people were moving the hell out of there
supply and demand
the enhanced affordability here's a
quote right here the enhanced
affordability caused
a surge in newly signing since september
as tenants
move around the city looking for better
deals you're biting you're bopping
you're moving around looking for a deal
and inbound migration has expanded
kai i know we talked about this
yesterday how much does it cost to rent
a one bedroom
in new york city so the most expensive
city in the country so we found
on average uh the number was two
thousand three hundred and seventy five
dollars for twenty four hundred bucks
yes that's right now
that was uh i believe that that's right
now yeah and that was a twit and then
and what was it last year
we saw there was a 21 decrease from last
so right now you're talking about 27
2800 bucks
for a one bedroom in new york city
you're paying almost three grand
okay so new york's making a comeback is
that what's happening right now
is this a good sign the pandemic i mean
what's happening in new york it's a
great sign i mean we need new york to be
strong not everybody can move to palm
palm beach county yeah i just drove
through it we're here in palmyra you
went to boy and you're with the boca you
would drove back yeah i mean there's not
enough room for everybody to come to
palm beach and and worth avenue isn't
big enough for everybody to shop on that
street as opposed to fifth avenue
i think this is great this is
encouraging i mean it's depressing to me
to think that new york
was struggling the way it was i went to
new york in february right before
pandemic yeah and literally right yeah
literally right before
and just walking around um times square
and broadway and everything packed
no no i can already sense a little
change
it was last year garbage was you know
everywhere and that's just leadership in
that city that we could go on about de
blasio
but we need america to be strong i mean
excuse me for new york city to be strong
you know it would destroy the country if
new york were to
you know continue to you know decline
like they were last year it's still the
hub for
advertising for finance and and for a
lot for media and for a lot of major
important things
in this world so i'm excited to hear
encouraging news like this
exciting new york making a comeback are
you ready to move to new york what do
you got kai
let's let's do it no i think uh but i
definitely think i agree with tom in the
sense that it's uh
good news because obviously it's it's a
turning point uh
because all the other stories we've been
talking about new york is them leaving
this person left that person left that
company moved this company one of my
closest friends who
moved down here from new york he said
every single one of his thing
of single friends moved to south florida
every
single one he said all the married
people with kids they stayed there yeah
you're a little more tied down you're
more established you know they're living
in long island whatever but he said
every single one
they had the opportunity to move he's
like yeah they're all down here in miami
they're out there they're on brickell
they're out in south beach
they got the hell out of there yeah but
it seems like a year later almost
reality setting back in new york new
york's not dying i mean jerry seinfeld
did a big thing like
new york ain't going nowhere okay don't
bet again but that was more a pep talk
that he was given at the time because it
was going somewhere it was going south
and he kind of needed he almost sounded
like he was delusional saying that
but this is good a positive sign like
this can only have ripple effects for
the rest of the year
well i'll tell you what man if you told
me a year ago
one year ago because usually in the
summers so i've been doing the remote
work thing like before was like
wfa work from anywhere wfh work from
home i've been working from home working
from anywhere for like
almost 10 years now like like people
have been wondering how do you do that
like remote thing
before it was you know in vogue right
now and i said so every
word or expression was invented oh
before you even born
bro four hour workout or even bore
exactly and
so usually in the summers i would um
at well at one point i was dating a girl
from london so i would spend some time
in london we'd do the europe thing
but i always love new york
so if you told me a year ago and i would
spend summers in new york as well
if you told me a year ago where will you
be living during this pandemic
this summer and the options were
new york city or addison texas i would
be like bro it's not
what you're even freaking talking about
everything changed
things have changed things have changed
as a pandemic
so it's good to see new york city making
a comeback i mean save that money move
around
find a spot that you know things are
shooting i mean
vacancy is down or vacancy's up so i
mean it's it's uh
yeah but crime's up and that's what they
got to get their handle on i mean crime
is way up is crime up in new york really
oh yeah yeah la big time
mm-hmm la big time okay thank you sam so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye